Hôm nay đỉnh số 1 có chỉ phụ, mất lương cơ sử tăng lên, 2 phải năm 8 triệu đồng một tháng.
A phụ giọng được việc cán bộ công chức viên chất lực lượng vũ trang, và cơ đối tượng hưởng lương thà quy định.
Vì điều trình cũng làm tăng nhiều khoảng trợ cấp, chỉ độ bảo hym sã hội và tất chính xác an dịch liên quan.
Còn viết đó, theo nghị định số 1 xóa 2, kể từ ngày 1 1 tháng bẩy,
người đang được hưởng lương hư, chợ cấp vào hym sã hội và trợ cấp hàng tháng.
Đối điều trình tăng tăng tăng phần chăm, sau với mất vượng tháng 6, hành hình thương trong 1 xóa.
Đối với người nghĩ hư, trên ngày 1 1 tháng 6, 5 14,5.
Còn mất vượng thấp nhà nước tiếp tục đều trình để bảo đam mất vượng tối thiệu thật quy định.
Chính phụ chở biệt, cách tên lương sẽ tiếp tục đều trình khai, theo lộ trình phụ hợp video kẹn phát chính thình tế và khả năng tình đường nơi xách,
gần với nước các hiệu khoảng tạo nộ của Bộ mái và cơ trẻ trả lương theo hiệu khoảng công việc.